said i ran as a democrat i'll govern as  president  for all the people whether they voted  for me or not  so i am so  officially pleased with the outcome that  is  imminent and also personally delighted  because of the quality and caliber of  leadership  that joe bryan will provide this morning  it is clear  that the biden harris ticket will win  the white house  his election is historic propelled by  the biggest vote ever in the history of  our country  73.8 million and counting  americans the most votes ever received  by any presidential ticket in history  president-elect biden has a strong  mandate to lead  and will have a strong democratic house  with him  and many democrats in the senate this  has been a life or death fight for the  fate of our democracy as he says the  soul of our country